[Musik]
schönen guten abend hierbei bild die
große energiekrise damit beschäftigen
sich die g7 zu dieser stunde in ellmau
bei garmisch und wir alle ja wir hören
auf die worte des wirtschaftsministers
der sagt das wird schlimmer als mit
corona ohne russen gas gehen bei uns die
lichter aus die richtigen fragen zu
großen energiekrise hierbei bild an
fritz vahrenholt er war hamburgs
umweltsenator ein pionier der
energiewende
manager bei shell bei rwe und
streitbarer energieexperte michael kruse
er ist für die regierende fdp der strom
und gas experte im bundestag hans walter
boris vom bundesverband schutz
kritischer infrastrukturen der blackout
experte in deutschland henning jaske
ergreift für sein klima protest zu
radikalen mitteln hungerstreik
festkleben auf der straße klima aktivist
bei letzte generation und gleich bei uns
der sendung auch simone peter vom
verband der erneuerbaren energien sie
kennen sie noch aus ihrer zeit als
grünen-chefin ihnen allen schönen guten
abend erfahren heute als politiker haben
sie ich habe gerade schon gesagt voll
auf erneuerbare energien gesetzt das
erste windrad in der nordsee das ist
nach ihm benannt das heißt fritz dass
sie uns auch immer noch das heißt immer
noch fit und haben sie trotzdem
inzwischen den glauben verloren an die
energiepolitik hier in deutsch ich habe
ja immer die erneuerbaren energien
unterstützt allerdings war mir immer
klar wir werden die in der lage seien
100 prozent zu machen weil wir haben
natürliche schwankungen wir haben eben
mal auch zehn tage kein wind wie jetzt
zum beispiel und wir haben eben auch im
winter und nachts fallen die keine sonne
also erneuerbare energien funktionieren
dann wenn sie einen backup haben und das
ist glaube ich das geheimnis
der aktuellen krise nicht wir haben uns
auf dem backup von gas verlassen wir
haben die kernenergie abgestellt haben
die kohle abgestellt und jetzt wundern
wir uns dass
erneuerbare energien zusammen heute also
wind und sonne
5,1 prozent des primärenergieverbrauchs
abdecken strom haben sie im größeren
anteilen zusammen aber wir reden ja über
wärme mobilität wir wundern uns sagen
sie das heißt wir alle vor allen dingen
jährigen etwas völlig falsch
eingeschätzt völlige fehlkalkulation
die regierung hat in ihrer letzten
koalitionsvereinbarung ja angekündigt
sie wollten noch 30 neue gaskraftwerke
bauen weil ihr bekannt war und bewusst
war jetzt wollte man mehr erneuerbare
machen noch mehr windräder noch mehr
sonne die dann nachts nicht scheint also
muss man noch mehr gaskraftwerke bauen
das war der hintergrund für nord stream
2 man braucht er wies putins gas wollte
man die energiewende absichern und das
ist gescheitert das
sehen wir jetzt im zeitraffer dass die
energiewende wer also gescheitert jetzt
in den nächsten monaten uns wirklich zum
absturz bringen kann sie haben sich
verkalkuliert sagte fahren heute sie in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag sich aber auf
das gesetzt was jetzt halt nicht
funktioniert was sie jetzt plötzlich
nicht mehr wollen wir werden die
gaskraftwerke trotzdem brauchen und
nicht erklären auch warum weil genau das
stimmt was erfahren heute gesagt hat hat
er vollkommen recht wenn er sagt wir
haben die sonne und wind nicht immer zur
verfügung das bedeutet wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir aus sonne und wind so
viel energie produzieren und umwandeln
dass sie auch zur verfügung steht wenn
sonne und wind mal nicht zur verfügung
stehen und das bedeutet wir brauchen für
den ausbau der erneuerbaren nicht nur
mehr es gibt ja in zukunft nicht nur ein
kraftwerk auf der nordsee sondern wir
planen 70 gigawatt im moment ins 11
sondern wir müssen auch dafür sorgen
dass das was überschüssig ist und das
wird immer mehr dass wir das mitnehmen
wenn die zeiten wo wir keine
erneuerbaren haben zum beispiel über die
umwandlung in wasserstoff und das
schaffen wir nur wenn wir im
erneuerbaren-energien-gesetz was wir
jetzt gerade verhandeln eine speicher
strategie implementieren und dann
endlich den einstieg finden dass wir die
erneuerbaren auch haben wenn sie nicht
zu vergessen klingt alles so
optimistisch aber tatsächlich ist
totaler pessimismus gerade angesagt in
der regierung nachdem was der herr beck
gesagt hat ende dieser woche der stellt
uns im grunde darauf ein dass aus der
dass die heizung nicht mehr anspringt
sagt dass wir weniger duschen wie dicht
stehen wir herr boris an einem blackout
im herbst im winter ich glaube wir haben
alle nicht auf dem schirm gehabt kein
politiker kein gutachter dass eine
situation seit dem 24 2 eintritt die man
im grunde mit einem wirtschaftsembargo
kriegs wirtschaftsembargo bezeichnen
kann von seiten russlands die
wirtschaftswoche hat vor kurzem gesagt
kriegs mangelwirtschaft die ausgerufen
wird wenn wir eine abhängigkeit von
teilweise 52 55 prozent gas haben
importen aus russland 30 prozent schafft
norwegen 18 12 prozent schafften die
niederlande dann muss uns bewusst sein
dass eine einseitige abhängigkeit von
einem großen lieferanten sehr sehr
gefährlich wird wenn derjenige uns jetzt
den gashahn stückchenweise zu dritt wir
haben daraus sich auf 60 prozent dann
müssen wir uns sehr kurzfristig gedanken
machen was wird in den nächsten wochen
monaten dass es plane eines krisen
management und uns bereitet die sorge
dass wir in einen kalten herbst in einen
sehr kalten winter reihen laufen und wir
dürfen nicht auf das prinzip hoffnung
setzen sondern wir brauchen jetzt er
sagt es erlösung kurzfrist also dieser
blackout das ist kein horrorszenario
mehr sondern das ist ein szenario was
sie nicht ausschließen können da kann
man derzeit nicht ausschließen
insbesondere wenn wichtige energieträger
wegbrechen wir haben zum beispiel 12 bis
16 prozent für gaskraftwerke
wenn ich diese gasmenge nicht mehr habe
ist die frage wie viel kann ich noch in
die gaskraftwerke stecken also fällt ein
wichtiger part raus in wenigen wochen in
wenigen monaten gehen die letzten drei
akw vom netz wir wollen zahlreiche
kohlekraftwerke bis 20 30 35 stilllegen
dann müssen wir fragen wie können wir
das subsumieren über 24 stunden am tag 7
tage die woche 365 tage im jahr auch
wenn die sonne nicht scheint und bin der
wind nicht weht freuen sie ist kann er
jetzt aber ja genau jetzt schon an einer
schon habt uns dass ich heute die
freudigen jetzt das dafür sorgt dass wir
jetzt peschke klimaaktivisten da habe
ich gesagt sie greifen zu radikalen
mitteln festkleben auf der straße
kanzleramt beschmieren hungerstreik
haben sie gemacht mitten im wahlkampf im
gespräch zu erzwingen mit den
spitzenkandidaten freunde sich jetzt
über diese energiekrise in deutschland
weil sie wollen ja sowieso sie wollen
das land was die energie angeht
runterfahren ja ich frag mich wie sich
irgendwer freuen kann in der aktuellen
situation die ja krisengeschüttelt ist
wie kaum eine zuvor ich glaube im
übrigen dass die leute die auf die
erhitzung aufmerksam machen und auch auf
die weiteren gefahren von fossilen
energien dass man kriegstreiber
unterstützt und terrorregime überall in
der welt nicht nur russland aber jetzt
gerade natürlich am deutlichsten dass
man hätte man auf die gehört darin eben
zu sagen man baut um jetzt gar nicht in
dieser scheiße so tief drin stecken
würde mal salopp gesagt ich bin hier bei
die richtigen tragen glaube ich weil ich
denke die richtige frage heißt jetzt
eigentlich warum reden wir noch nicht
über die verbundenheit von all diesen
krisen miteinander also der ert
erhitzung auch eben einer welt in der es
immer mehr darum geht wer hat zugang zu
nahrungsmitteln es wird ja ungemein viel
in der ukraine in russland
produziert an weizen und insgesamt
steuern beraten die größten
hungerkatastrophe der
menschheitsgeschichte das ist
klimakatastrophe plus krieg und deswegen
ich hier bin ist glaube ich um zu sagen
wir schaffen es immer noch nicht die
richtigen lösungen zu finden wenn wir
das problem nicht in gänze betrachten
das heißt es entstehen todeszone um den
äquator und es werden allein in diesem
jahrzehnt 700 millionen menschen sich
aus dem afrikanischen kontinent in
lebensbedrohlichen situationen befinden
wenn wir nicht aufhören diese erhitzung
weiter anzutreiben das ganze wird
soziale konflikte bringen die leute die
jetzt gerade neu geboren sind in
deutschland die werden erleben wie der
krieg weiter wie weitere kriege
entstehen wie vielleicht sie rekrutiert
werden müssen wie das ganze ich richtig
ekelhaft wieder werden wird in der
gesellschaft an den grenzen ich glaube
ein rechtsstaat kann das nicht überleben
was dann an klimakatastrophe kommt
extrem wetter und so weiter hitze wald
wir leben ist halt die frage wer denn
jetzt vorsorgen und wir sagen es hält
sich die regierung nicht an die
verfassung die die lebensgrundlagen
nicht schützt und damit eben uns
weiterhin kriege führt aber freuen sie
sich darüber dass jetzt das land
heruntergefahren wird das jetzt appelle
von der regierung kommen ihr müsst
sparen sparen sparen energie sparen das
ist doch genau ihr thema das wollen sie
doch also das finde ich jetzt ein
bisschen absurd glauben sie dass wir
eine freude daran haben dass es den
menschen irgendwie schlechtes daran dass
ich mich an straße auf eine straße
setzte um also glauben sie dass mir das
freude macht ja doch ich bin ich wollte
es sehr wenn es frau ich bin hier um zu
erzählen dass die richtige frage jetzt
eigentlich diese warum redet immer noch
niemand darüber was ich gerade gesagt
habe ich gerne dass die nächste als
nächstes zu sagen dann einer klima
erhitzung und den erfolgen getragen
werden wird die schauen sich den
deutschen wald doch anja was erzählen
sie denn den menschen also jetzt gerade
evakuiert werden in den rennen geht
richtig gut so gut wie noch lange nicht
und sie müssen einfach ein bisschen
aufpassen dass sie unter den jungen
menschen nicht solche angst psychosen
verbreiten lesen sie bitte den
weltklimabericht und der sagt ihm wenn
wir so weitermachen und die pariser
ziele erfüllen was übrigens nicht für
china geld nicht will sie wissen in
china ein entwicklungsland darf immer
weiter co2 emittieren darüber müsse noch
einmal diskutiert
aber wenn man das so machen dann haben
wir in 2060
22 grad ja und wir haben 2040 haben wir
0 3 grad mehr das ist doch keine
katastrophe darauf kann man sich doch
anpassen sie müssen doch mal ein
bisschen zu den fakten kommt lehren sie
doch bitte mal die 2000 seiten des klima
berichts und dann diskutieren weil wir
kamen sie es gelesen ich glaube wir
haben alle gelesen was da ist er
zusammen mit wirtschaft rausgekommen
sind haben sie eben das wiederum sendung
sollte kann nicht 30 das können wir nach
der sendung
die begannen muss nicht berichte von
3000 seiten länge neu delhi berichte als
auch die aktive wehr schon super kannst
dich mal an die bevölkerung brauchen
einfacher sprache jetzt die wahren was
das bedeutet was da drinsteht was da
drinsteht was das bedeutet sie haben
doch keine ahnung erzählen sie doch mal
wie die realität ist das ziemlich egal
was du dir das eigentlich weiß ich jetzt
machen wir einmal schnitt bei 1 für die
muss ich schauen die für die zuschauer
einen schon mal drei jetzt schon für die
inzwischen 1,4 die zuschauer ist es in
dem fall wichtig welche katastrophe man
sich widmen soll sie haben gesagt welche
katastrophe für sie wichtig ist für die
zuschauer ist im moment ganz greifbar
das was im portemonnaie passiert der
herbst der winter sie sagen herr bau ist
das ist ein realistisches szenario dass
wir ein blackout sogar überleben im
herbst und die zuschauer fragen sich was
passiert zum beispiel noch in den preis
muss sich jetzt geld zur seite legen wie
kann ich dafür dass ich möchte ich über
das sozial als schwerpunkt sind und ich
glaube wir werden nicht den strom
blackout bis zum herbst wie ein glas und
sonderling gas mangel blackout es gibt
eine sehr interessante studie des
bundesverbandes für energiewirtschaft ev
vom 17 märz 2022 was die substitution
potenzial und einsparungspotenziale
aufzeigt wenn gas weniger kommt oder gar
nicht kommen es zeigt uns dass haushalte
maximal wenn geworben wird wenn wir alle
bürgerinnen bürger mitnehmen 10
eventuell 15 prozent einsparen dass wir
im industriebereich 4 bis vielleicht
zehn prozent einsparen können das
ergebnis war aber alle
einsparungspotenziale für
dienstleistungen handel verkehr und und
verkehr mit gas fahrzeugen machen
maximal betone maximal ein drittel der
gasmengen aus russland aus wenn russland
nur noch 40 prozent liefert oder gar
nichts liefert werden sämtliche
einsparungspotenziale spreetal
arbeitsplätze kosten darum geht es ja
ich meine preise ist schon schlimm genug
aber was im augenblick überhaupt nicht
diskutiert wird übrigens auch nicht von
dem bundeswirtschaftsminister der ja für
die wirtschaft dieses landes
verantwortlich zeigt dass wir
möglicherweise mit sechs millionen
arbeitsplätzen sprechen müssen der
bruder müller von der basf sagt wenn ich
kein gas mehr kriege dann ist die basf
dicht in ludwigshafen und das bedeutet
für die gesamte chemie kette das
bedeutet kein glas erzeugung mehr das
geht weiter bis zu den
brötchen backen die ja auch nicht
geschützt sind sondern geschützt sind
der private haushalt und dafür werden
wir das gas auch haben die krankenhäuser
die öffentlichen einrichtung das wird
alles mit gas versorgt aber wir reden
über 50 prozent des gases die gehen in
arbeitsplätze und ich wundere mich
wirklich wie ruhig die gewerkschaften
sich das angucken was da im augenblick
passiert weil das was habe ich jetzt
macht und sagt wir geben so ein bisschen
kohle frei
weg den gas
den den gas
kraftwerk haben nicht ab da noch eins
sagt wenn sie dann noch am 31.12 drei
kernkraftwerke abstellen die immerhin
35 terawattstunden liefern die können
sie dann ja gar nicht mit kohle da
verdenken
die kraftwerke haben sie gerade wieder
einmal auf diesen blackout gedanken zu
sprechen kommen sie sagen brutale gefahr
für die arbeitsplätze in dem der
situation muss die regierung müssen auch
sie abwägen wem lässt man eigentlich
noch das gas und wem nicht im moment
gilt die regel die verbraucher sind
versorgt es ist schwer zu glauben dass
das noch so bleibt wenn die
arbeitsplätze plötzlich verloren gehen
weil die industrie nicht mehr
produzieren kann und das in der fläche
können sie so eine garantie geben oder
wie werden sie so eine energie so eine
gastritis situation dann lösen wer
bekommt das gas noch und wer nicht wenn
man erstmal seinen die situation in der
wir jetzt sind hat nicht die neue
regierung zuvor okay das haben wir ja
schon deswegen die entscheidung man
hätte ja jetzt übernehmen wir die
regierung und gucken uns an wie ist das
eigentlich bisher geregelt es ist gar
nicht geregelt man hat einfach nur
gestrigen regeln als erstes abgeschaltet
haushalte müssen wir regeln wir regeln
ist so dass wir jetzt mit der gesamten
wirtschaft vor allem mit den großen
verbrauchern mehrere tausend mit denen
wir jetzt erstmalig ins gespräch
gekommen sind als regierung und dafür
sorgen dass wir wissen wo wird was
produziert was darf auf keinen fall vom
netz gehen weil es große schäden an den
produktionsanlagen gibt und in der folge
dann auch große volkswirtschaftliche
schäden mit arbeitsplatz das ist doch
eine hohe scheinende frage jetzt für die
richtige reihenfolge aber nochmal aber
war er hat ja ihre meinung der
hauptpunkt lautet wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir gar nicht in die
gasmenge lage kommen
ich frage sie treffen angeregt wir haben
ihr antwort ganz klar sagt ganz korrekt
weiter frage nicht beantwortet als
rekurse ich stelle die frage wie treffen
sie die abwägung und sie sagen wir
gucken wie wir die abwägung treffen so
nicht so gerieten gegen sie sind die
letzten juni arbeitslos erfahren heute
den auch geschichten und unser garten zu
hause die heizung wird ein langes waren
wir entscheiden von mir nicht nur die
richtigen fragen antwortet das ist jetzt
setzt sie was hören sie das erste gesetz
was wir durch den deutschen bundestag
gebracht haben ist dass wir die
gasspeicher befüllen die gasspeicher in
diesem jahr sind weiter eher winter im
rahmen bleibt und das ist gutes glas
speicher sind jetzt sofort das war die
antwort auf meine frage sie haben die
latte ganz hoch gelegt und jetzt muss
die einfach kommt ja so ja ich der
bundesnetzagentur dafür dass wir genau
wissen welches unternehmen was
produziert was auf keinen fall
rausgenommen werden und dann gibt es
eine ganz klare reihenfolge von uns ja
wie ist die reihenfolge da sind wir doch
gerade daran werden von der
bundesregierung davor nichts bekommen
wir bundesregierung davor weiß nicht mal
wie man auch zu hause bringen das wissen
rechnen wir mit der wirtschaft wir
können doch jetzt als politik nicht
darüber entscheiden wer abschalten
sollen wir sprechen mit der wirtschaft
bisher saß der grundsatz die verbraucher
können sicher sein die haben die
garantie die sind zuletzt daran vorher
wird die industrie abgeschalteter hört
bei ihnen strauss gilt nicht mehr ich
will jetzt gar nicht durchzuhalten ja
ich möchte noch mal durchmachen der
präsident müller hatte ganz deutlich von
der bundesnetzagentur gesagt die letzten
tage wenn unsere gasspeicher voll
sondern es kommt eine notlage und
vielleicht wird 22 halten monate würden
die gasspeicher erreichen wenn sie sich
den notfahrplan gas anschauen stellen
sie fest dass auch die geschützten
kunden die bürger bezug nimmt auf einen
kalten winter
2011/2012 30 tage wahrscheinlich nur das
gas bekommen werden die speicher voll
sind und spezielle industrien vielleicht
rufe sieben tage wenn die speicher
folgen ich habe mir mal die derzeitigen
steigerungsraten angeschaut die liefen
pro tag in der vergangenheit bevor putin
darauf um 60 prozent reduziert hatte um
ein prozent 0,8 prozent derzeit sind es
0,3 bis 0,4 prozent was machen wir in
wenigen wochen mitte juli wenn die
nordstream 1 leitung aus reparaturarbeit
er komplett abgeschaltet junge grieche
so weiter zu beschreiten muss man aus
reparatur gründen die dann vielleicht
länger dauern dann bekommen wir kein gas
dann werden wir auch die mehr ein
speichern können das heißt wir kommen
nicht über die 60 59 modellen genau um
diese frage für sich beantworten also
was müsste in so einem notfallplan drin
stehen wie viele arbeitslose würden sie
in kauf nehmen bis man den verbrauchern
zu hause das gas weg nimmt ich würde
kaum arbeitslose in kauf nehmen wenn ich
basf mir als standort anschaue der gn40
bis 50.000 arbeitsplätze es ist eine
stadt sofort relativ schnell verloren
verlustig wenn 50 prozent gas leistung
nicht mehr es schaffen aber das wäre was
wir jetzt tun müssen ist jetzt schon gas
einsparen wir sind in einer ganze
perversen situation die deutsche gas
kraftwerke laufen fast auf volllast weil
wir ströher an frankreich gereist da die
atomkraftwerke in verhilft der krise das
ist wunderbar das sagte uns der
soziologie unterstützen gerade
frankreich weil die ihre kernkraftwerke
nicht im glas sagen uns jetzt sorgen wir
als erst jetzt hat die regierung hole
kraft das heißt bleiben das ist golf
geschaltet es läuft jetzt bei der
regierung wie bei corona da hat man uns
auch immer gesagt liegt jetzt in eurer
hand wie schlimm die krise ist einfach
maske auf ordentliches verhalten wie
schön es ist liegt bei euch an und jetzt
läuft es in der energiekrise wieder
genauso dabei hätte man möglicherweise
einen hebel erfahren wollt einfach
atomkraftwerke bisschen länger laufen
lassen das würde nicht alles helfen aber
es wird den schmerzen natürlich lindern
aber ich denke wir sehen auch wir müssen
noch ein bisschen weiter graben wir
müssen sehen dass über nur die jetzt
abzustellen kohlekraftwerke nicht
abzustellen das ist jetzt die diskussion
ein wir müssen auch über die
reaktivierung der alten reden in hamburg
gibt es ein hoch modernes kohlekraftwerk
in moorburg es hat ein 1600 megawatt das
kann ich ihnen gar nicht vorstellen was
das bedeutet wir müssen das alles im
gasmarkt das ist erstmal die erste frage
und zweite frage geht aber über den über
den winter hinaus du kannst natürlich
auch nicht den mitarbeitern sagen jetzt
kommen wir für drei monate wieder hier
rein und mach mal und dann bist du
wieder nicht gewollt weil wir haben ein
völlig negatives verhältnis zu fossilen
quellen und man könnte sie man könnte
sie sauber machen es hat eine technik
gegeben co2 kraftwerke mit abscheidung
mit co2 abscheidung dann haben sie ein
sauberes kohlekraftwerk und das hätte
einen großen effekt wir könnten die
chinesen sagen das macht ihr bitteschön
auch und das muss der nächste schritt
sein kohlekraftwerke mit der in
deutschland verbotenen ist verboten
obwohl der weltklimarat sagt ihr müsst
ccs das heißt dass sequestrierung ihr
müsst co2 abscheiden aber nicht immer
ist verboten da sagt der weltklimarat
zumal
ich möchte aber jetzt einmal einbeziehen
in dieses gespräch simone peter die
mittlerweile dem verband für erneuerbare
energien vorsitz die sie zu hause aber
vor allen dingen auch noch als
grünen-vorsitzende kennen schönen guten
abend frau peter die diskussion ist voll
im gange hier in studium und bei bild
bei den richtigen fragen und herfahren
holt den sie bestens kennen der hat
gerade die frage aufgeworfen nach der
atomkraft das müssen wir natürlich und
nach der kohlekraft ganz genauso aber
erstmal atomkraft frau peter sie
vertreten den bundesverband erneuerbare
energien wie man hitler hin noch einmal
in der schrift aussieht vertreten sie
damit auch die grüne energie der
atomkraft wenn ich so fragen darf
naja ich vertrete tatsächlich die grünen
denn den kindern dass es sonne wind
bioenergie wasserkraft und erdwärme die
atomkraft wird dieses jahr abgeschaltet
da sehe ich auch keine debatte mehr
gerade hat die woche der
rwe-vorstandsvorsitzende gesagt das ist
eine rückwärtsgewandte debatte wieder
haben wir die brandstelle und auch das
personal aber es hilft uns wie eben auch
schon darunter gesagt ja gar nicht für
die versorgung von gas sondern ist
lieferant und deswegen muss es jetzt
darum gehen und das sehe ich auch
irgendwo schadenfreude dass man einander
gemüt jetzt aber eine regierung dass man
überlegt wie kriegt man die gasmenge
zusammen und hilft nur bemüht nicht
darum dass man das lng jetzt
diversifiziert dass man andere quellen
sucht aber ganz wichtig ist dass anfangs
gesagt wurde wir müssen mit sonder- und
wind deutlich mehr ausbauen und gar
einen überschuss zum beispiel auch
grünen wasserstoff zu bilden wir haben
aber auch potenziale bei der bioenergie
denn man kann gestern beschlossen dass
sie bis 2030 mit fossilen heizung
rausgehen also aus gas und den rest mit
bioenergie verfüttern und wir haben im
moment die silos bei den landwirten voll
wir haben etwa 9500 biogasanlagen die
artrock zwei millionen haushalte mit
biogas versorgen können er liegt auch
ganze die hoffnung darauf peter die
frage ist nur trotzdem und sie können
jetzt sagen die debatte findet gar nicht
mehr statt die debatte läuft doch längst
die debatte läuft sogar in der
bundesregierung vor allen dingen durch
die fdp-minister befeuert die debatte um
eine verlängerung der atomkraft wenn da
noch ein bisschen ein teil zumindest der
lösung liegt wird nicht klar warum sich
die grünen dem weiter verschließen wo
warum auch sie sich dieser debatte wie
sie gerade gesagt haben verschließen
also zum beispiel atomkraftwerk isar 2
könnte man einfach verlängern sagt der
betreiber sogar selbst sagt einfach wir
könnten einfach so ohne dass es groß
fasst kostet einfach monate länger
laufen lassen das würde doch in der
situation total helfen alles andere wäre
ja unterlassene hilfeleistung im moment
für die verbraucher
ich habe es hier gerade versucht zu
erklären der strom hilft uns hier nicht
mal gras ansatz also wir haben im moment
die situation dass darüber diskutiert
wird dass man kraft kohlekraftwerk in
der sache und ich war ja immer mal
energie minister im saal und ich weiß
dass da kraftwerke bundesweite der
reserve sind die kann man auch nutzen
allerdings
dass jemand niemand hieß es eben
angesprochen worden dann müssen sie eben
bei jetzt schneller um schnell
erneuerbare energien bis zum jahr 2030
noch mal in eine andere phase wenig
entspannt aber jetzt kurzfristig müssen
die da können sie ein stück beitragen
und da sind ja auch die brennelemente
verwandten allen atomkraftwerken
sehe ich weder den willen der betreiber
noch tatsächlich den nutzen und es geht
jetzt darum vor einigen gas
bereitzustellen hier zu diversifizieren
und da kann ich nur sagen wenn wir jetzt
auch zum beispiel bei der bioenergie
stärker die reststoffe nutzen würde die
biomasse die auf grünland oder
biodiversitäts flächen anfällt nutzt und
eben die deckel in den gesetzen anfangen
aber auch eine möglichkeit aber es muss
vor allem darum gehen den gesamten
erneuerbaren energiemix jetzt ganz
schnell auszubauen ein paar neue japan
läuft ganz kurz das zwischen konkreter
wenn ich da verfahren
überzeugt noch
erfahren ganz kurzer zeit kann einmal
einmal das zwiegespräch zu lassen frau
peter erfahren heute überzeugte sie das
dass frau peter jetzt sagt na also
atomkraftwerke das hat ja mit dem strom
nichts zu tun das würde jetzt erstmal
mit blick auf die gaskrise vor allen
dingen überhaupt nicht
es ist natürlich völlig falsch weil
natürlich die abstellung von ich sag dir
135 terawattstunden kohle kernkraftwerke
bedeutet das wie gaskraftwerke
hochfahren müssen und dass wir mehr gas
verbrennen müssen wenn die
kohlekraftwerke haben wir leider nicht
in dieser dimension wird zur verfügung
es ist einfach so es ist eine ideologie
man hat eine ideologische position und
ich sage mal voraus ich das wird
unvertretbar das wird die regierung
nicht durchhalten sie können nicht eine
gesamte nation so einsperren die
arbeitsplätze vernichten nur weil sie
ihre die ideologische grüne position wir
wollen möglichst schnell aus der
kernenergie raus aufrechterhalten das
wird nicht funktionieren
wir reden über eine verlängerung von 23
jahren bis wir diese krise vielleicht
bewältigt haben und wer dazu nicht
bereit ist der sag ich mal ganz offen
der gehört nicht in die bundesregierung
ganz ganz eindeutig sind muss sie ja
über respektieren dass wir unser eigenes
gas auch mal sehen also nicht mehr das
aufgeben trotzdem trifft auch die
ideologie von herrn fahrenholz sie
sitzen immer noch einer ideologie auf
und sind nicht bereit alles zu tun damit
die verbraucher versorgt werden
also ich finde das wort ideologie immer
von denen in die debatte geworfen die
sonst keine argumente haben ich fit und
habe den rwe-chef zitieren rwe
vorstandsvorsitzender der diese woche
gesagt hat die debatte über atom
laufzeitverlängerung also ist vorgestern
sie gequält jetzt
überlegen natürlich liefert kohle strom
und wärme und es geht darum gas zu
ersetzen da muss man doch einfach mal
die fakten zur kenntnis nehmen die
verfahren nicht zur kenntnis nimmt weil
er sagt atomkraft würde jetzt etwas tun
das ist den leuten den x5 okay jetzt in
einem punkt der debatte wo frau peter
sagt der fan hat hält sich kein
verfahren holz sagt ich darauf hätten
sie dann zu ende reden ja mache mache
ich
ja wir haben einfach mit der atomkraft
du hast wenige prozent dass wir 34
prozent die dann bleibt noch mehr
liefern wir haben aber in das problem
ein wärme problem aber wir müssen jetzt
dafür sorgen dass die haushalte und
industrie am jahresende genug wärme und
genug gas haben um die industriellen
prozesse nicht zu stoppen und nicht zu
massenarbeitslosigkeit zu führen rasch
darum geht das bemühen das ist der
zentrale punkt hilft uns die atomkraft
und stand mal kurz in das nehme weil
sonst da sonst das ideologisch sich auch
eine scheindebatte zu versteifen die uns
aber gar nicht hilft
der situation ich lebe selber an einer
fan der maschine gehe zum beispiel die
stahlindustrie im saarland versorgt dort
gegen kohlekraftwerke mit jetzt an lässt
dann können die strom und wärme liefern
die atomkraftwerke tun das nicht das
muss man einfach zur kenntnis nehmen
grüne die jetzt auf kohle setzen aber
sie sagen naja ideologische debatte ist
das nicht erfahren holz sagt doch ist
immer noch sie wollen die positionen
nicht räumen ihr wirtschaftsminister
grüner wirtschaftsminister sagt das
zählt jede kilowattstunde sie sagen ist
doch ein paar kilowattstunden damit dem
mit der atomenergie haben wir einen
strich drunter wann wäre denn erfahren
heute hat eingang ist der sendung gesagt
erfahren hat eingangs der sendung peter
gesagt dass erneuerbare energien das
ganze land darüber versorgen können dass
das wird nicht funktionieren sie sagen
hundert prozent geht dann ginge das denn
also wir haben gerade eine studie mit
zwei fraunhofer instituten gemachtes
tragen die ist es realistisch dass die
bundesregierung 80 prozent des strohs
bis 20.30 100 prozent bis 20.30
erreichen will dafür müssen jetzt die
rahmenbedingungen in den usa paket der
bundesregierung gestellt werden und
dadurch dass wir immer mehr strom auch
in den anwendungen berner durch
wärmepumpen oder mobilität
elektromobilität nutzen schreibt nicht
rum wenn ihr gehen trotzdem muss man
natürlich das hat man fahren wollte
anfangs zu recht gesagt wir müssen in
ghana bereitet jetzt weiß ich auch noch
vorsorge treffen deswegen steht die
bioenergie oder auch die geothermie es
gibt jetzt gerade neue potenzialstudie
münchen versorgt er seine gesamte dame
zum beispiel bei der academy dass wir da
in deutschland noch mehr potenzial haben
solarthermie müssen jetzt booster puck
aber aus den weg gebracht werden damit
wären die nächste jahr monat nicht
hingenommen können für die nächsten
winter und dann sind wir der überzeugung
dass wir bis zur mitte des europa das
die
klimaneutralität aber auch mittel allen
sektoren und prozent erneuerbare
energien schafft mitte des jahrhunderts
nehmen wir mit finden sie den klima
protest auf den straßen wie eben den von
herrn jeschke eigentlich zur zeit
sinnvoll nützlich
da sehen sie ich kann die jungen
menschen gut verstehen die sich jetzt
wehren dagegen dass sie passte sich
wirklich weise keine zukunft haben wir
haben vor wenigen wochen erlebt dass in
indien die dehydriert also ausgetrocknet
vom himmel freien nach in den letzten
wochen erlebt das fahren in frankreich
deutschland unter extremer hitze aber
fehlt ist wird sich dafür auf der straße
zu kleben über die frage des protests
kann man sich sicher unterhalten
menschen ausgeht und es geht natürlich
nicht darum die gesamte gesellschaft in
mithaftung zu nehmen aber die ungeduld
dass die politik jetzt gut steuern muss
von fossilen auf erneuerbare
energieträger und dass die
internationale
staatengemeinschaft jetzt handeln muss
und wirklich weg von den fossilen
energieträgern den unmut verstehe ich
okay du gehst von alex frei also eine ex
grüne die sagt darüber kann man streiten
und trotzdem richter solidarität heraus
mit denen die sich auf die straße kleben
so wie es die
ja
die realität mit der jungen leute nicht
absehbaren sogar noch wachsen werden
will ja ich auch immer krise in den
ausprägungen haben
ich habe auch kinder danke frau peter
herzlichen dank für das gespräch herr
streiten hier im studio weiter und das
gespräch dort am tisch das habe ich die
ganze zeit gehört das ging fleißig
weiter her erfahren holt vor allen
dingen unter jeske haben hier weit will
wählt weiter gestritten jetzt sagt frau
peter gerade funktioniert eben doch mit
den erneuerbaren energien sei
erstaunlich mitte des jahrhunderts aber
ja das sagt sie ja natürlich aber kann
man alles technisch machen man kann
natürlich auch mit wasserstoff
zwischenspeicher man muss nur wissen
dass vier mal so teuer das heißt am ende
ist die frage wenn du das als nur als
deutschland machst oder sogar nur als
europa die chinesin das mit nicht
mitmachen und die amerikaner dann wird
in diesem land jedenfalls keine
industrie mehr stattfinde ich kann ihnen
sagen weil der verdopplung des des
strompreises wandert hier die halbe
industrie aus und deswegen muss man doch
erstmal sich die frage stellen lassen
lassen sie mich mal bitte jetzt zu
entleeren lassen
ich bitte zu ende die günstigste ich
habe hier auch nicht unterbrochen jetzt
machen wir einmal der reihe
und daniel jeschke bisschen disziplin
muss schon sein also mein punkt ist
bevor man jetzt hier die den gesamten
wohlstand sozusagen kopf heißt da gehen
ist da muss man sich doch mal die frage
stellen
warum fördern wir eigentlich nicht unser
eigenes erdgas wir haben ihnen dann
steht da unter schiefergas wir haben
heuer sachsen und sachsen anhalt und
mecklenburg vorpommern
ungefähr so viel schiefer gas das wir
uns 20 bis 30 jahren mit versorgern
siehst und die bundesanstalt für
geowissenschaften erster war das finde
ich großartig aber die sagen ihnen in
einigen jahr haben wir das wir wissen
genau wo das liegt aber es kann doch
nicht wahr sein dass wir sagen wir nun
und trekking gas aus usa aber hier
machen wir das nicht hat heute der
wirtschaftsminister aus niedersachsen
gesagt das wollen wir nicht weiter kann
ärger haben wir natürlich gibt es ärger
herrscht doppelt so nicht jeder antwort
muss auf jeden fall gemacht werden
herfahren und herrsche ich finde es ein
wenig widersprüchlich es wird gesagt
lesen wir die berichte wenn wir die
berichte lesen ist klar fracking gas das
ist der atmosphäre egal ob sie aus
amerika kommt oder von hier ist sowohl
bei der förderung als auch wenn man es
dann als gas verbrennt alles
tödlich es wird unsere gesellschaft
auseinander treiben in kriege bringen
und die deutsche landwirtschaft das
merken wir jetzt schon hat von jahr zu
jahr mehr zu kämpfen ich komme aus
vorpommern da will keiner fracking gast
klasse die leute wollen wirklich dass es
einen klaren gibt deswegen werde ich
vielleicht mit menschen die fakten
straight up ignorieren nicht mehr
sondern wir können uns nicht gegenseitig
geben auch vorwerfen habt ihr bei
ferrari droht jungen ist das können wir
nicht aber der atmosphäre ist das jetzt
ziemlich egal ob die realität verleugnet
wird oder nicht die ist ja einfach da
die waldbrände sind ja da in brandenburg
brennt treuenbrietzen wird evakuiert das
geschieht ja man kann jetzt viel
irgendwie sagen fühle ich nicht so aber
das wird also jetzt juckt die wollen wir
ja nicht die waldbrände juckt nicht ob
jemand das jetzt ja unbedingt hause
leben heinrich sommer gegangen hat die
unangenehme wahrheit ist doch dass
während sich hier können sie mal kurz
raus suchen wir hier in der runde uns
immer noch nur über das nächste jahr
irgendwie gedanken machen in dem wieder
was kommt der plan überhaupt nicht
weiter reicht und eigentlich müsste es
heißen wir sind erwachsen genug in einer
katastrophe in einer krise die bedeutet
was auf 700 millionen menschen sich auf
die flucht machen und eine todesliste
gesamt auch wasser entstellt aus noch
beenden das ist relevant für uns ja alle
und ich nicht verstehen wie wir das
unterbrechen das dann die nächsten jahre
insgesamt eine notfall wirtschaft
helmand sei der wohlstand dschungel ja
das gefährdete stellen wir genau die
sachlage narkose nicht wir machen wir
machen die ganze küste ausbau der erneut
vorher machen wir eine ganz kurze pause
und wollen aber auch wissen herrschte
wie wir alle eigentlich kurzfristig denn
das ist ja der appell der
bundesregierung sparen können die
bundesregierung und da waren wir gerade
schon an dem punkt hier am tisch fordert
ja von uns jetzt brutal einzusparen wie
das hier am tisch gehandhabt werden nach
einer ganz kurzen pause ist
zurück bei bild die richtigen fragen
ohne russen gas gehen dann bei uns in
deutschland möglicherweise schon in
diesem herbst in diesem winter die
lichter aus erstaunlicher sparappell
kommt da von der regierung von
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck der
von sich aus gehen sagt duscht doch
weniger in deutschland ich robert habeck
so sagt er macht das doch schon lange
ich habe noch nie in meinem leben länger
als fünf minuten durch und jetzt
verkürzt sich das nochmals sagt er jetzt
gerade das hier sein aktuelles zitat
schneller check hier in der runde beim
politiker der mit in der regierung
zahlten sie ist schon an robert habeck
chapel ich durch bei der hitze immer
kalt
unter und im winter wird das ist ja im
winter wird spannend im winter durch
stürze kürzer ok dabei als kaffeebohne
uk robert habeck chapel wie oft und wie
lange duschen sie klima aktive ist bei
uns in der runde henning jaske ich war
recht festgeklebt ist ich frag mich ob
er die sendung umbenennen müssen wir die
richtige frage hieß sie jetzt in diesem
moment eigentlich nicht wie ich meine
stoppuhren jetzt testet beim duschen
gericht aber ich kann das verstehen dass
sie jetzt sagen dann gucken wir mal wie
das alle machen aber das ist eigentlich
eine lüge begonnen von der ölindustrie
die hat gesagt gucken wir alle uns
unsere eigenen fußabdrücke an wieviel
machst du denn so was isst du denn
eigentlich so die bewegst du dich und
alle streiten sich und die die leute die
den privat jets über unsere köpfe
wegfliegen die lachen sich doch schlapp
dass wir können ja jetzt auch nicht bei
jeder frage sagen das ist totaler
quatsch ich habe hier die besseren
fragen nein aber ich nachgefragt weil
dann können wir am nächsten mal tauschen
und sie moderieren deshalb lassen sie
uns einmal bei der frage sind hier weil
wir gerade der gesellschaftlichen kann
das kind auch wir sind extra und aber
ist es auch egal sich weniger an viel du
schicht sondern wie viele werden
insgesamt die hebel umgestellt und dann
darf man weg vom immer nur das hatten
sehr selber angesprochen gehen wir auf
dein kleines was machst du ein sondern
an die russen ja mal sein und die großen
hebel heißen jetzt sofort den
bahnverkehr anders umbauen eine
verkehrswende zu beanstanden aber an
starke sache aber sie beschäftigen sich
nicht mit ihrem eigenen verhalten also
ist es wurscht wie sie zuhause heizen
oder wie lang die dusche läuft das ist
ja der punkt den robert habeck anspricht
der pakt ja uns am gewissen das heißt
sie fühlen sich da gar nicht gepackt von
robert habeck sagt er muss halt an die
langen hebel ran bei mir zuhause wurscht
oder wie handhaben sie ich habe eine
große menge von leuten in den
gesellschaft ist auch schon seit
geraumer zeit daran zu überlegen wie
kann ich in diesem klima notfall etwas
verändern ja eine tonne kostet natürlich
auch jetzt genau in der lebenszeit groß
wie viel da die kosten kommen und im
krieg was mache ich das persönlich sind
viele überlegen aber das ganze wird ja
nur dann groß funktionieren das war
schon immer gesellschaftlich so dazu ist
politik da wenn ihr regeln insgesamt
sagen so ist der plan so kommen wir da
raus und wenn wir uns erwachsene sie
wird zum angucken heißt das wir müssen
über die nächsten fünf jahre sonst
nämlich werden die leute die jetzt neu
geboren sind in kriege geschickt die um
die letzten ressourcen bekämpft werden
also herrschte alles in ordnung hatte
einfach nicht die einfach einfach hier
bereiten könnte daher sein könnten tag
das kann ich ihnen alles sagen aber ich
glaube dies das ist nicht die
entscheidende fragen deswegen habe ich
nicht gesagt es ist die frage die die
regierung aufgeworfen hat stark gespielt
habe schnittlich der weiß wie die leute
duschen soll wohl irgendwie am tag bei
elf minuten liegen ich glaube ja viele
kommen bei drei bis vier minuten aus
halten die temperatur oder gar nicht so
niedrig wie nur möglich ich darf noch
mal betont das einsparungspotenzial der
haushalte vergessen dass darunter ist
auch duschen aber es ist heizen es ist
auch kochen kennen und nun liegt bei
maximal 10 bis 15 die entscheidende
frage ist wegen felix wir sind uns der
springer investieren als user kampagne
an die bürgerinnen und bürger zu bringen
dass man sieht ich kann einen beitrag
leisten alle müssen einen beitrag in
dieser versorgungsmangel lage aber eine
aufklärungsarbeit muss für die bürger
auf schon darauf schon fast zynisch wenn
ein bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt du
schon ein bisschen weniger also ich
dusche nicht richtig durch und nicht
weniger weil ich sage dieser hebel ist
so klein ich weiß ja worüber wir reden
das ist wenn wir zehn prozent und
außerdem muss man wissen die menschen
sind klug genug bei solchen dreifach
sechsfach steigenden gaspreisen schon
selber auf die idee zu kommen mit
energie vernünftig umzugehen das macht
übrigens jedes unternehmen also diese
appelle jetzt musste auch das
unternehmen ersparen die blöd sind die
denn eigentlich denken die eigentlich
den unternehmen das sind alles
schnarchnasen haben die ganze zeit
optimiert ich sage wir müssen können das
problem nur lösen wenn wir auf der
angebotsseite endlich mal die barrieren
brechen die in deutschland auf gestürmt
worden sind dann hat ein gas teurer und
verbot wir haben ein fracking verbot wir
haben ein kohle erscheinungsform suchen
kann sich die kernenergie forschung hin
total gut aus hamburg sie war im umwelt
in hamburg sie haben die beste zugänge
sie kennen kanzleramtschef den wolfgang
schmidt haushaltes la vida ist alles
weiß und man isst man muss aber immer
sehen dass die gesellschaftliche
diskussion wie sie im augenblick geführt
wird eben soweit noch nicht ist das
heißt der kanzler weise sei
alles nur abstellen und wir müssen jetzt
möglichst nur erneuerbarer machen das
wird aber nicht funktionieren und wir
müssen immer von der realität ausgehen
und ich sage ihnen voraus wenn
diejenigen die in diesem land
sozusagen das rückgrat bilden dieser
dieser volkswirtschaft und für unseren
wohlstand jeden tag morgens um 7 uhr zur
arbeit gehen das sind die interessen
sorgen diese all das können sie mich mal
bitte ausreden lassen diese
undisziplinierter ist doch unglaublich
sie haben kann jetzt mal über die
katastrophe eigentlich geredet ja weil
es keine katastrophe gibt man lieber
machen sie doch mal schlau 0,3 grad das
ist doch gar nichts sie kleben sich
umsonst irgendwohin und stören ist nicht
gleich also den menschen hat er war ganz
was anderes nicht um ihre
fantastereien und ihre angst preziose
sie sie haben die gibt es nämlich gar
nicht 0,3 grad ist gar nichts im in den
nächsten 30 jahren das werden sie noch
hoffentlich auch als jedes hat das
wasser hat alles was so lange an
korrigieren weil in so einer runde sowas
unkommentiert stehen zu lassen ist
natürlich es ist gar nicht lang
kommentiert da ist habe sie sagen herr
vahrenholt er hat keine fakten erfahren
sagt die hin sie haben keine
nennen sie beim platzen moderator wie
sieht's aus herr jasch beantworten sie
einfach darauf sie sind in der lage sich
selber zu werden hier in dieser sendung
an fanden sie einfach auf erfahren heute
erfahren heute sagt es gibt keine
katastrophe er leugnet durch den
klimawandel das hat er nicht getan er
sagt aber der anstieg ist nicht so groß
und vor allen dingen sagt er wir sind
nicht die letzte generation wie sie das
sagen hat ihr aktivismus wie erfahren
holt offenbar sagt was religiöses
absolut also ich brauche das fegefeuer
und ich sehe wie egal es ist für unseren
weiteren lauf was der liebe erfahren
heute sagt weil es einfach komplett
daran vorbei geht was die menschen
mittlerweile schon selber erleben ich
komme aus vorpommern da ist die
blaualgen blüte der deutsche wald jeder
spürt dem los und ich war 20 jahre es
ist klar dass das ganze jetzt gerade in
die kib situation kommt psycho die dürre
in der landwirtschaft jedes jahr mehr
milliarden braucht und das wird
irgendwann nicht mehr über geld zu lösen
sein weil wenn das ökosystem einmal 90
seiten damit nur genau über die mittel
und die schriftlichen klar geworden was
verstanden dass wir immer noch darüber
streiten und ich dachte da sind die
leute einen schon weiter ich freue mich
wenn wir nicht mehr darüber streiten
müssen dass das eine notfall ist in dem
wir ganz ehrlich gesagt mal in den
nächsten zwei drei jahren noch
entscheiden können wie ob die also in
100 jahren wird man sich auf den
parkplätzen von supermärkten wenn es
noch welche gibt um reis schüsseln
kloppen und sich gegenseitig umbringen
das ist die zukunft in die wir kommen
und schon in den nächsten jahrzehnten es
ist ja gar nicht pessimistische es ist
ja ganz pessimistischen blick auf die
welt teilweise wird er eben nicht
geteilt es gibt einen optimistischen
blick auf die auf die welt dann sind sie
zwischen anbelangt keinen anlagen aber
keinen anderen auf die fakten aber wir
streiten doch hier über die mittel wie
gehen wir das andere was sind lösung das
interessiert auch unsere zuschauer zu
hause was hat beispielsweise die
hungerstreik gebracht im wahlkampf
können sie da sagen der protest auch das
leben auf der straße das hat bisher
etwas gebracht
es ist immer so wenn es die situation
gibt das gesellschaftlich sehen wir noch
mal bilder von ihnen verzeihen sie ja
das ist dieser hungerstreik im wahlkampf
der sie körperlich an die grenze geführt
hat
sofern wir das zumindest sehen konnten
was hat da es bewegt was hat das
gebracht genau wir sehen hier wie in den
momenten in denen in unserer
gesellschaft vor der vor der wahl
beispielsweise nicht darüber geredet
wird was eigentlich die leute besorgen
sollte kein anderer weg mehr dazu führt
dass das in die debatte ein fluss findet
auch hier nicht richtig in die debatte
ein fluss finden kann als darüber dass
man deswegen sitze ich ja hier sagt es
muss ganz anders gehen und das nicht nur
bei sich im kleinen stückchen sagt
sondern so war das in der geschichte
immer wieder wenn es katastrophale not
gibt das auf den straßen sagt das ist
der ort wo wenn eine regierung darin
versagt die menschen zu schützen die die
jetzt neu geboren werden davor zu
schützen dass an der außengrenze wieder
erleben wie das richtig richtig übel an
formen annimmt wenn das nicht geschafft
ist dass ich sie für sich und seine
schergen
adidas einen massenerfolg ja genau und
in der brachter der erfolg ist doch dass
in der debatte mittlerweile klarer wird
wir können so nicht weitermachen noch
deutlicher wird jetzt darüber dass die
fossilen energien keine mehrheiten mehr
haben jetzt die versuchen einige
verzweifelt im ringen um ihrer letzten
profite das wieder zu etablieren
herkommer so wird das was herr jasch wer
sagt dass er für die letzte generation
spricht was ist das ist das in ihren
augen ein stück anmaßend wenn er das
formulieren dass viel zu viel
pessimismus für die zukunft wir haben
doch in jeder phase der
menschheitsgeschichte selbst auch
kontrolle darüber erlangt wie wir wieder
in die zukunft kommen es gab immer große
krisen es gab immer große
herausforderung für die menschheit und
es gab immer aber auch die möglichkeit
ist selbst zu prägen und deswegen ja es
ist anmaßend über instrumente die dafür
sorgen dass der rest der gesellschaft
gestört wird und zwar bei vielleicht
auch da gerade dabei diesen wandel
hervor zone vorzunehmen dabei dabei
irgendwie zu stören und ich meine die
debatte können wir auch führen wenn sie
nicht auf der straße fest geben wir
können sie sogar besser führen sind sie
nicht auf der straße leben ja dann
müssen wir heute das alles
jetzt lassen sie mich aus und ich habe
sie auch ausreden lassen sie nehmen
immer einzelergebnisse um dann zu sagen
das nehmen wir jetzt ganz groß und dann
haben wir ein riesenproblem so ist die
welt aber nicht sie lesen ein erstes mal
den 1,5 grad bericht des pcs die sagen
atomenergie die sagen also ccs
technologie und design wir müssen das
alles machen und dann suchen sie sich
wenn sie denn dafür hier sprechen mich
mehr einzelne sachen davon auch die sie
besonders gute filme anderem sondern
diesen dabei dass das alles hier denn
hier sorgen drei mal dazwischen da sehen
richtig ex verein in black out experten
dazwischen wir streiten darüber auch
welchen hebel wir eigentlich haben und
da sagte jeschke wir haben nur den ganz
großen hebel dann können wir über die
kleinigkeiten über die peanuts und so
weiter sprechen bringt aber nichts wir
müssen die ganzen salat isst schon
wissen ganz kurz die frage es würde
schon wissen weil es ja hochspannung mit
blick auf herbst und winter es gibt es
eigentlich so was wie den kleinen
energie hebel von uns allen der aber was
ganz großes bewirkt wenn wir das alle
tun denn das ist ja was was robert
habeck insinuiert wo sie sagen ist
quatsch alle weniger duschen und es
bewegt richtig was gibt so war jeder
einzelne von uns
bürgerinnen bürger zu hause oder in
einem unternehmen auch im handwerks
mittelständischen unternehmen im
dienstleistungssektor kann ein gewisses
einsparungspotenzial erreichen dieses
einsparungspotenzial reicht aber nicht
aus
60% minderleistung von russland oder 100
prozent zu kompensieren insbesondere
wenn wir dann andere energieträger
auslaufen lassen ich darf er dann wir
haben drei akw s jedes bringt 1400
megawatt also 1,4 gigawatt wenn wir 4,2
gigawatt die 8000 nennen las stunden im
jahr haben vom vom netz nehmen haben
eine grundlast die nicht mehr da ist
darf erinnern
2020 hatten wir erneuerbaren energie
anteil an der stromversorgung 47 prozent
dann kam 2021 eine leichte delle 42
prozent wir haben 20 jahre gebraucht um
mit erneuerbaren energien wenn ich den
begriff überhaupt so gebrauchen kann den
energie kann weder erzeugt vernichtet
noch erneuert werden das ist ja schon
der punkt in der sache wir haben 20
jahre gebraucht für 47 prozent
ich glaube wenn wir zurzeit 1000
windräder haben die wir nicht mit trotz
genehmigung an den markt bringen weil
die baugenehmigungen nicht da sind die
umsetzungen die stadt mit unternehmen
die das schaffen dann werden wir in den
nächsten zehn jahren nicht die
verdoppelung hinkriegen wir werden
vielleicht auf 50 55 prozent kommt wir
werden aber dennoch eine dunkelblaue
haben in der nacht die es im winter
wesentlich länger im sommer kürzer wir
werden flauten in der wind phase haben
die photovoltaik wird dunkel bleiben
bestimmten sachen und dann darf ich
betonen wir erleben heute das wie ein g
7 gipfel haben deutschland als viert
wichtiges industrieland kann ich ein
agrarland werden es brauch am tag zur
spitzenzeit 70 75 gigawatt also 75
tausend megawatt in der nacht 40 45.000
wenn ich dir aber nicht erzeugen kann
durch erneuerbaren in der dann wird sich
jeder unternehmer fragen wo bekomme ich
meine energie wir haben als
bundesverband festgestellt dass wir
schon im kleinen bereich im
millisekundenbereich im sekundenbereich
große ausfälle haben wie zum beispiel
eine bäckerei unternehmen sofort im
bereich 500.000 euro schaden bei nur
wenigen sekunden hinein fahren wir
brauchen eine energie die immer da ist
die keine schwankungen hat und die kann
man einander nahe kunden wenn das
passiert die firmen gehen einfach dahin
wo energie usa ist verhallt als erster
die ja strom und gas ist nur ein viertel
so teuer wie hier was ist ihr großer
hebel sozusagen wenn wir hier über die
kleinigkeiten über die peanuts
gesprochen haben über das was wir zu
hause tun können tun sollten
möglicherweise was ist der große hebel
der unseren gewinn bringt schon herbst
winter meine große hoffnung ist dass wir
mit den tabus die wir aufgebaut haben in
einer selbstzufriedenheit der letzten
zehn jahre geht doch schon irgendwie
dass wir damit jetzt mal in dieser
krisensituation
brechen als tabu 1 ist eigene
gasförderung in einem jahr haben wir so
viel gas mache auch nur dass russen gas
da bin ich der fdp sehr dankbar
ich finde die fdp sehr dankbar ich hoffe
dass die sozialdemokraten endlich auch
verstehen dass das vernünftig ist und
die gewerkschaft hat ihn auch
entsprechend kulisse entschuldigend
einheizen hat nach kruses scholz und das
zweite ist wir machen und wir müssen die
enttabuisierung der der der kohle
thematisieren das heißt wir müssen uns
damit beschäftigen wie machen wir kohle
saubermachen die crew ihren stand haben
wir frau peter gehört worden waren die
machen kohle für sechs monate und dann
ist alles wieder gut dann wollen wir weg
davon aber wir müssen doch gemeldete
dafür zwei jahre früher 7,5 jahre aber
auch für zwei jahre wird ist ja nicht
reichen wir werden ja auch in zwei
jahren noch energie brauchen und wir
haben die große chance wir haben die
technologie im land gehabt wie es war in
brandenburg die technologie zur co2
abscheidung entwickelt die sind dann
nach kanada ausgewandert und das werk
ist abgerissen worden in kanada wieder
aufgebaut worden wir haben die techniker
wir haben ingenieure das zu entwickeln
damit china das ist nämlich der
entsprechende mit 30 prozent des co2
weltweit endlich seine kohle schätze
nicht einfach so in die luft pusten darf
sondern sie abscheiden muss weil wir
sagen wir können das auch das ist ein
bisschen teurer das kostet nicht alle
drei und tabu-thema doch
wir werden irgendwann russland auch mit
russland wieder reden können nach diesem
krieg und nach kopien und es wäre völlig
blödsinnig zu sagen wir werden diese
pipeline nie mehr nutzen das wäre doch
absurd da ist die diplomatie gefragt zu
sagen wir werden sicherlich auch bei
kollegen haben wollte klaus es zu ende
ist glaubt ihre regierung nicht dass die
das durchhält glaubt nicht nur das dass
wir das hier soziale spannungen geben
sie die preise durch die decke wir wenn
wir gas rechnungen von 2000 euro
betroffenen menschen in der ukraine
abzuschlachten die unter wird überhaupt
nicht darüber dass überhaupt nicht
darüber rede ich jetzt nicht ich habe
nur gesagt wir werden russland in fünf
jahren nicht von der kruste vertilgen
das wird sie werden das wir wollen
sollten auch nicht so
weit treiben dass das gesamte erdgas und
sagen in china landet das ist eine
koalition die ich auch nicht so gerne
habe also insofern sie so offen und
deine bilanz von jamal gasversorger
jahre klar und das dritte tabu ist eben
wir brauchen wieder gern
energieforschung weil wir haben nämlich
noch ein problem das dürfe nicht
vergessen dass die kernenergie haben wir
alte lassen wir haben radioaktive
abfälle die in deutschland keine lösung
haben die werden an den kernkraftwerken
in
zwischenlagern gehortet das kann auch
mit technik sie haben gerade technisch
ja gerade schon gesagt ich sehe die spd
bewegt in einigen punkten kriegen sie
die grünen auch bewegt dass die am ende
des jahres sagen dass wegen fallender
also forschung muss auch die diskussion
ist so so schwierig geworden hier für
uns wir werden jetzt zumindest mal
anfangen isar 2 laufen zu lassen
bisschen länger vielleicht auch mal zu
gucken immer noch brennstäbe importieren
können also in der koalition muss sich
immer jeder selber bewegen wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass die gasförderung in
der nordsee wieder in der debatte ist
und wir werden jetzt dafür sorgen dass
dafür auch sehr bald lizenzen ausgegeben
wird also das fördert
gasförderung in der neue lack ihnen
jetzt mal was wenn wir energie
importieren aus den usa anstatt ist
dann braucht das 20 prozent mehr energie
sie
erklärten sie lassen mich erstens
ausreden und zwar erklären sie mir
gleich warum es besser ist das gas aus
den usa zu importieren als selber
nachgefragt ist quatsch das ist image
und der herr nach atomkraft gefragt und
ich sage ihnen jetzt mal wir beantworten
sie ruhig die frage von herrn erich
heute dass wir danach was ich möchte wer
danach geboren ich möchte dass wir
danach rasch verstanden habe ich dann
ist hier ein sind daran liga will auch
wind auf see ausbauen die super damit
den ausbau der erneuerbaren den es in
der geschichte der republik gegeben hat
das ist ja nun jahren mich nachher kraft
ich hab kein problem damit ich habe kein
problem damit wenn noch ein bisschen die
frage so wichtig warum haben sie so auf
die soziale damals prozent des umsatz in
deutschland kommen immer noch aus
russland und wenn es deutsches öl gibt
in der nordsee dass wir da fördern
können sagen wir dafür dass öl aus
russland abstellen können dann ja dann
werden wir es hier fördern das sind
klare einhorn und wir kommen ja klar wir
wollen die gesellschaft ist so lang dass
man da es kommt auf jede kilowattstunde
liegen sagt der grüne
wirtschaftsminister das öl kann man ja
im verkehr einfach einsparen die man
darüber wollen sie lieber weiter ich
habe also ich habe der verkehr einsparen
wenn man es so macht wie die bevölkerung
schon lange bereit dass wir sparen damit
tempolimit wenn man eine günstige bahn
hat das sind sachen die lastwagen 100
und ganz viel strom denn dann überhaupt
keine filme an das ganze ist nicht
beantwortet auch die frage verstehen
aber schon dass die auto jetzt wir
brauchen die die menschen nutzen wenn
die bahn sich
umso mehr russland ohne salär eine einer
haben andere vereine nach dem anderen
was versteht hier keiner mehr was sie
sagen immer sie kommen nicht zu wort und
ganz viel gesprochen wenn jetzt
antwortet einmal hätten habe ich noch
die kernkraft ein freier wollten sagt ja
selbst verstecken sich die spd bewegt
wir haben jetzt als erstes man den
betreibern gesprochen die betreiber
haben gesagt wir können isar 2 weiter
genau und das bedeutet das gutachten was
uns vorgelegt wurde das offensichtlich
nicht so richtig gewesen im hirn und
deswegen braucht deutschland jetzt einen
kernkraft gipfel um zu besprechen ob die
kraftwerke noch länger am netz bleiben
können auch um gas raus zu drücken auch
um kohle raus zu drücken aus der
stromproduktion kommen wir jemals ganz
kurze antwort bitte jemals aus der
kohlekraft raus wenn wir diese sorgen
und nöte hier ernst nehmen und sie na ja
ich kann mir das schon vorstellen aber
ich muss natürlich wissen dass china die
nächsten 15 jahren nicht aus der
kohlekraft rauskommt und bis 2060 immer
noch mal 200 300 kohlekraftwerke bauen
wird dh den müssen wir helfen dass deren
kohle das werden wir nie hinkriegen das
zu verbieten dass die umwelt riesige
werden sich die ausgangsposition
verändern werden wir jährlich oder noch
in kürzeren abständen an energie
sicherheits monitoring machen müssen und
überprüfen ob ziele wie 20 30 20 35 37
38 ob die einzuhalten sind oder
gegebenenfalls ob sich nach hinten
verschieben weil krieg hatte niemand auf
dem schirm gehabt das haben wir nochmal
gar nicht betont seit 24 den zweiten
haben wir eine situation mit der hatte
niemand gerechnet wir hatten den ewigen
frieden mit vorwarnzeiten von zehn
jahren scanner und wir sind jetzt in
einer anderen situation gehen nämlich
doch und die lichter aus möchte noch mal
durch sich heraus dass wir niemals
striche und herzlich oder die sendung
kurze antwort putin sanktionen die
sanktion gegen putin treffen die uns
eigentlich gerade wenn wir hier die
debatte mit der leben härter als ihn
selbst nur noch so ist es und der öl
boykott hat dazu geführt dass putin sein
öl nach indien verkauft und die kinder
verkaufen das wieder an den usa und in
europa das ist wird kaufen teuer zurück
dass ich
danke an herrn boris danke einen cruiser
und danke an herrn jetzt dieses in der
runde zumindest am schluss noch die
führendes fort wir führen eine sendung
zu ende ist jeder diese jungs leider zu
ende wir danken uns alle mir in der
runde die diskussion geht hinter den
kulissen weiter und bald auch wieder
hierbei gilt gerne dasselbe gestern
verlassen die richtigen fragen an land
gegangen
[Musik]